[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream number 210 I'm Dr
Brett Weinstein you are Dr Heather hying
and we are here on Wednesday January
31th yep the very last day of January
somehow we are rocketing through 2024 a
12th over already amazing in fact a bit
more than a 12th over if we're being
precise no actually with leap now we're
still more than a 12th over still more
than a 12th over yes but we are also
more than a third of the way through the
northern
winter more than a third yes no oh more
than a third yes more than a third see
exactly more than a third which is is
good it makes the chances of us
surviving the northern winter that much
better yeah no and it's it's always it's
an interesting time of year because um
you know the days are often getting
colder um but the day length is changing
pretty rapidly at this point uh you know
I was at uh it was at our local co-op
yesterday just after 5 and was
commenting to the woman Manning the
cashier the woman Manning the cashier um
how light it was still outside which is
which you know a month ago it was well
dark by five so anyway it feels good it
feels like uh things are looking up
um relatively short time scale
astronomically I can say less about how
well things are looking up right here on
the planet but that's what we're going
to talk about today a little bit Yeah
but the planet is a small piece of the
big picture just keep that in mind it's
really not helpful I think it's helpful
we are earth based we are Earth but 2024
is going to be a wild r right I think
people just need to realize that that's
just just right here it doesn't
matter I think it does and my guess is
there are seven or eight people out
there who agree with me and some of them
might be Darkhorse viewers
so so please join us on locals uh we
have had a great uptick in our local
subscribers this last week since uh we
put out uh a private conversation that
you had with Chris Martinson at the end
of your shared trip to Panama including
the Panama Canal and the deren last week
uh and that's just that's behind the
locals paywall also available at Chris
martinson's um Peak Prosperity Channel
and um there have been there we we just
are putting a lot more stuff up there on
locals we did our private Q&A there this
week uh and that's still available and
there will be more stuff coming out
there um reliably now so please do come
join us there right now there's a watch
party going on at locals and uh and to
be to get all that content um that you
do have you have to pay that's behind a
pay wall uh you can also just be a
member of locals you don't get as much
access but you will hear when when stuff
is happening and please do also join our
channel on Rumble that cost you nothing
um but it helps us out we're trying to
hit 100,000 subscribers in the next
couple of months and uh we would really
love your help to do that so if you're
watching uh even if you're if even if
you're watching somewhere else hop over
to rumble and uh and join the Darkhorse
uh Rumble Channel and and while you're
there you might consider joining us on
locals as well want say anything else
about that no I just think it's great
and I think the more people who are
there the Richer the community is so it
it's sort of a self-catalyzing
phenomenon absolutely and we do do uh
some amas there as well um there's
there's lots of good stuff there um drop
our guest episodes early there um lots
lots lots of good stuff over at locals
okay uh we're going to move the rest of
our stuff uh to the end except for our
sponsors uh whom we uh choose carefully
we vet carefully and uh we are very very
pleased to have them so you know that if
uh you hear us read now we do three at
the top of the hour and then we don't do
any throughout the rest of the show um
if we are speaking um words on behalf of
sponsors you can know that we have um
that we really do truly vouch for them
okay without further Ado it's um Maui
newie American Hartford gold and free
spoke this week our first sponsor this
week is Maui Nei venison that's Maui is
in the Hawaiian island Nei Nu UI venison
they are new to us this year and we are
so excited to be working with them Maui
Nei venison is a mission-based food
company bringing the healthiest red meat
on the planet directly to your door we
absolutely love this meat and the
mission of the company the meat is
extraordinary and in both taste and
nutritional value it's not gamey and
it's easy to cook and the company is
amazing and unusual in several regards
everything about this company um oh I
repeated a line there um they're
actually both environmentally and
socially responsible and that's not just
uh lots of companies say that sort of
thing and sometimes they don't mean it
at all and sometimes they're actually
doing things that are neither
environmentally nor socially responsible
Maui newi is actually both responding to
the problem of Maui's invasive access
deer population Maui Nei venison is
helping to restore balance to vulnerable
ecosystems and communities in Hawaii by
harvesting a limited number of deer they
are seeking to restore balance to Hawaii
not eradicate or Farm these animals they
limited maroi venison is limited in how
many animals they can Harvest but more
impressive than that they do so in a
stress-free way wild harvesting fully
wild meat in a completely unique way
using forward-looking infrared
technology to give them eyes in the dark
they hunt exclusively at night always
with a USDA official in attendance with
such Precision that only the animals
targeted are impacted by the hunt plus
Maui Nei venison has donated over 16,000
pounds of meat to Hawaiian communities
that have food insecurity amounting to
over 43,000 meals distributed research
out Utah State shows that the meat from
Maui Nei venison is the most
nutrient-dense and protein dense red
meat available this is nutrition of
place the deer live on volcanic Rich
soils which support remarkable plant
diversity and the deer engage in true
wild grazing all of which give Maui Nei
venison the highest protein per calorie
up to 53% more than grass-fed beef we
highly
recommend excuse me we highly recommend
trying their allnatural venison jerky
sticks as well for an optimal protein
stack snack or their amazing bone broth
or any of their wide of Fresh Cuts all
available in their online butcher shop
they deliver the healthiest red meat on
the planet directly to your door go to
Maui Nei venison docomo horse to get 20%
off your first order of fresh venison
jerky delicious bone broth or even their
special Ohana box subscriptions
subscriptions which like the deer they
harvest are limited number that's M UI n
v n i s o
n.com Dark Horse to get 20% off your
first order do it today you will not
regret it it's truly amazing imagine
starting a company where there really
isn't some dark secret actually
everything about what you're doing is
good good for the people who are
consuming it it's really it's amazing
yeah that's really cool um our second
sponsor this week is American Harford
gold you're here listening to us so you
probably already know just how unstable
our institutions are becoming and how
incompetent are so-called experts
interest rates are Skyhigh we are cop
between runaway inflation and a
recession while being assured that
everything is fine the cost of food
housing Medical Care schools everything
thing is climbing our leaders
increasingly make no sense at all all of
this threatens businesses jobs and
retirement funds finding ways to secure
your nest egg and insulate your wealth
is more important than ever and adding
precious metals to your assets is a
great way to stabilize your Investments
and protect yourself financially
American Heartford gold is a precious
metals dealer that can help you do just
that American Heartford gold helps
individuals and families protect their
wealth by diversifying with precious
medals they make it simple and easy to
protect your savings and retirement
accounts with physical gold and silver
with one short phone phone call you can
have physical gold and silver delivered
right to your door or inside your IRA or
401K they are the highest rated firm in
the country with an A plus rating from
the Better Business Bureau and thousands
of satisfied clients and if you call
them right now they will give you up to
$5,000 of free silver on your first
qualifying order contact them today by
visiting the link in the episode
description below or call
8668281166
828-1114 or you can text Darkhorse to 99
8899 once more that's 8866 828-1114 or
text Darkhorse to
98899 now our final sponsor as you know
Heather is free spoke which you also
know is a search engine that we have
become very fond of and I'm going to
just Riff on why that is do it so we
live in a crazy era in which it is very
difficult to often establish even what
the facts are of a story that everybody
is talking about
you know you might see the White House
Press Secretary stumbling over
condolences for the family of dead
service members but the question is what
actually happened and where could you
even go now in the world that you and I
grew up in you could go to a newspaper
and you could discover the basic set of
facts and then you might find a
perspective on them that was part of
that newspaper now you can't even
sometimes even within the same newspaper
you would find two perspectives imagine
it and you can't now go to Wikipedia
because it might be that they report on
this story in a way that at least the
basic facts can be deduced from their
articles but it has become what the kids
call a risky click the fact is Wikipedia
is full of crap on lots of topics
including you and me so what are you
going to do well you can use free spoke
and free spoke allows you to search a
topic and then see a diversity of
viewpoints that are labeled by their
typical perspective you might find a
middle of the road perspective a right
perspective a left perspective and by
looking at those those things together
you can often figure out what took place
just by simply saying well all right
here are the facts that they all agree
on here are the things they differ and
what is the likely slant so the ability
to do that is something that is
essential and we are being denied the
ability to do that for ourselves by our
media environment so what we are going
to recommend is that you go over to free
spoke and you know what it's called free
spoke because it doesn't cost anything
which is really cool all you got to do
is just surf over there on your desktop
browser or download the app and you are
going to find the ability to deduce for
yourself what took place in events that
affect us all so
free.com is the
place to go check out frees spoke oh
check out frees spoke from your desktop
or in your App Store and download it
today to make it your default search
engine freesp docomo if you want to know
how it works all right thank you for the
assistance in the end there I was just I
was riffing I could have
gone on for an hour yes indeed I'm sure
they would have appreciated that sure we
have other things to talk about indeed
yeah you have a number of things you
want to talk about and I've got just a
little something cool and something
grotesque probably at the end yep so I
wanted to unpack a little bit there's uh
some stuff that's going to emerge into
the world soon and uh it involves some
hypotheses that are born of the
observations that Zach and I and others
were able to make down in Panama on this
recent trip and as longtime viewers we
have a lot of new viewers but there are
longtime viewers who know that we are
very careful about the Rules of
Engagement for lack of a better term
that one has to apply when dealing with
scientific hypotheses and I want to just
remind people a little bit about how
those rules work and then I want to talk
about two concepts that I believe are
going to become uh important in the
dialogue about what's going on uh in the
uh the border crossings in Texas the
crossings that are taking place in in
Darian and the migration that is
happening um in Northern South America
and all of Central
America so the first thing I want to
discuss is a hypothesis is a plausible
explanation for something that is
observed you are supposed to formulate
every hypothesis that could explain a
given uh pattern when you are trying to
sort what might be there so to say that
something is a hypothesis doesn't mean
that you believe it's true in fact there
should be a maximum of one hypothesis
for any given observation that you think
is more likely true than not and there
may not even be one of those right a
maximum of one which you believe in and
you might call that my hypothesis but
that's an ambiguous preferred hypothesis
right my preferred hypothesis or you
could separately say this is a
hypothesis I think is likely to be true
Still Remains to be tested but here are
a bunch of other hypotheses for the same
observed phenomena right so the fact
that somebody advances a hypothesis
doesn't mean they think this is the case
and this is a place people get very
sloppy and the fact that
we um you and I are careful about the
term hypothesis most people even people
who are scientifically very rigorous are
often sloppy about the distinction
between hypothesis and theory and they
treat them as synonyms and so this sort
of um blunt in strument that we've been
left with means that we get tangled up
we need to be able to talk about what
might be going on without saying that we
think it's going on and then we need to
separately be able to say actually this
one I suspect is probably true and
that's a separate level of belief so
we're going to talk about two
hypotheses um the first one has to do
with the basic observation
that there are a huge number of people
migrating North from South America which
Zach and I saw in person Michael Yan
showed us this migration in the Darion
of Panama he took us into the Darian gap
which is this Gap in the Pan-American
Highway 60 mile wide Gap in the
panamerican highway where the highway
has never been completed on the uh path
from northern North America to the
southern tip of South America Southern
North America to the northern tip of
South America I no the Gap is at
Southern North America but the road goes
from the bay to
uho approximately actually it does fork
down there they're two different routes
but never mind you can get all the way
from prudo Bay to the southern tip of
South America by Road except for the 60
mile gap which is in a an area of dense
primary
jungle a very important habitat because
most of these habitats have been logged
this one is difficult enough that it
remains largely intact but it has this
large migration coming through it many
of the people coming through it have
arrived in South America in Ecuador in
keto and the reason for that is because
there's no Visa requirement uh and
therefore people can come from all over
the world they can land in Ecuador and
then they can migrate through Colombia
and into
Panama but the hypothesis is this that
there isn't one migration that there are
in fact two migrations now maybe there
are more than two but I believe what we
observed was that there were two
migrations that had a distinct
character and that character looks like
this you have Migra you have one
migration that has many different
ethnicities from all over the world
places like
Afghanistan Yemen a lot of people from
Venezuela um it's a very diverse
migration and these are people who are
walking the most difficult path through
the Darion or one of them and then you
have another migration which which is
strangely separate and I don't want to
overdraw this distinction uh just before
you do that you didn't say so you said
uh Afghans Venezuelans I don't remember
what the third um nationality you
mentioned just then was but um
Venezuelans for instance we know we saw
when we were um leading a study abroad
in Ecuador in
2016 um I met a a few Venezuelans who
had been Professionals in Venezuela like
high high up uh you know doctors lawyers
uh business people who had fled in the
middle of the night uh from the
political chaos that was engulfing
Venezuela and I met them because they
were now running a restaurant in quena
in in Ecuador and talked to them and
actually um met a few other members of
their family and um and you know those
were the only people who I know from
this story uh but they reported um many
other members of their extended family
whom they were trying to encourage to
come and such so um you know to the
degree that Venezuelans are among the
people who are migrating there is real
political and socioeconomic conflict in
Venezuela that people are fleeing from
and uh presumably that is the case in
Yemen as well in in lots of places so
this is that that I think is the the
category of the first type of uh reason
for immigrants that you're talking about
yeah no I think there's been uh we
understand from those who have been
watching this migration unfold that the
people who are migrating out of
Venezuela have changed that the early
migrants were often people who had
significant resources they could afford
to flee yeah you know like like the
family I met right by aircraft they
could afford they many of them threw
away their careers and they went from
you know being doctors and lawyers and
whatever else to being restorators or
whatever they could figure out but um
increasingly the migration is moving
down the economic ladder people fewer
and fewer choices and what that is in
part doing is it means that the flight
is now this much more perilous one
through the D which is just it is there
people at the end of their rope and so
they are likely to end up forced to make
decisions that um people with Bo
resources would not be forced to make
right and I think it is safe to say um
you and I are very comfortable in uh
tropical forest we've been in many of
them um this is a tropical forest that
you and I would not cross lightly we
would think I mean it's probably not
simply not safe for uh reasons of human
Jeopardy but um even at the level of the
the physical difficulty of this
environment it is something you would
want someone who knew how to get through
the place and you would want to think
very carefully about how to equip
yourself and these migrants they're not
equipped have none of this they're at
the mercy of these snakeheads who are
like coyotes they get robbed along the
way and Equipment wise a they bring all
the wrong stuff thinking that they are
fleeing to the other side and that they
will want certain things with them they
end up jettisoning all of this stuff in
the Daran um yeah and you know they end
up uh sleeping on the ground without
proper insulation they get trench foot
it's a it's a it's a humanitarian
catastrophe yeah um but in any case so
that's the that's the first category of
first C that you that you are
hypothesizing that you were saying that
there are two different immigrations two
different immigrations which are frankly
on the ground in Panama largely housed
separately which is one of them things
that ought to make you think carefully
um so actually Zach do you have a
picture from the uh um Canan membo camp
Oh I don't have I think you do the T
yeah so there are Chinese immigrants so
this is the camp called Canan
mrio um and this is I believe that is
actually a Chinese uh aggregation in
this Camp which is almost entire IR L
not Chinese um so there are Chinese
people in this Camp um this camp we were
allowed to freely wander um the people
who are administering it talk to us
openly about what was taking place the
people who are administering it are
locals who um do not want the camp do
not think the migration is positive but
are stuck in a bind which is do they
want these people uncared for which is
more destructive or do they want to
provide the infrastructure for these
people um to live decently and they
they're clearly better off that way so
they're open about that in any case we
open we could take pictures we could
wander through this Camp the senafront
which is the Panamanian uh border
control Force knew we were present we
checked in with them they didn't make
any attempt to restrict our ability to
talk to people to take pictures nothing
we were completely free can I show the c
patch or is that not really yeah um yeah
Zach wants to show you the C but that
actually know that's from the different
that's from the other Camp so we'll come
back to it in a second so anyway there's
a highly diverse group of people who
have just emerged from the jungle they
are recovering in these camps so they're
at the North edge of the Darian Gap uh
as as as are you you you you didn't come
at it from Columbia you're at the Panama
end um so you have not um you know built
the highway and traversed you have not
crossed into the forest um but so these
people have emerged have survived uh the
jungle and are basically trying to find
their footing um before they continue on
their migration North right which
involves two things it reol involves
recovering from the journey you know
several days of eating food sleeping not
on the ground uh whatever injuries they
have uh get a chance to recover but they
also have to find money to get on the
buses that actually speed them through
Panama and into Costa Rica and points
north
um some of them most of them started out
with enough money to do that but having
been robbed in the Darion they have to
Now find a way uh to earn money and
these buses are um standard Latin
American buses uh put together by either
governments or private entities in
Panama Costa Rica Honduras Etc or are
they something else it is unclear they
look just like the other buses you would
see on the highway from outside it's
very hard to tell unless you happen to
see the occupants um now part of this
could just be standard Central American
entrepreneurialism where there's a bunch
of people going north they're willing to
pay to do it so buses show up and the
business starts and part of it may be um
facilitated by panamanians by other
organizations like the which we saw the
emblem of all over this migration stands
for this is the International
Organization for migration and it is a
branch of the
un uh which uh you should read their
website and their their white paper at
the website in which they have a at best
utterly childish understanding of the
impacts of migration they view it as a
purely good thing you know kind of the
way um naive economists regard anything
you pay money for as a good thing
because you're an agent who is entitled
to deploy money in your your own on your
own behalf and therefore it doesn't
matter that you're buying heroin and
that results in your overdose it was
still a valid economic choice it wasn't
the result of uh you know circumstances
that forced you into a bad choice or
anything like that so this these people
believe migration is simply a good thing
they're facilitating it I don't know
what their role is in uh producing these
buses these buses could be anywhere from
organic to synthetic and it would look
the
same um but okay so you have this
diverse migration that we are allowed to
look at we talked to many people in this
migration they all gave us the same
story about why they were migrating not
a single person said anything about uh
political oppression they all spoke
about Economic Opportunity as the thing
that had motivated them to face this
journey which means that when they come
across the southern US border they do
not qualify for political Asylum um and
yet that is the ostensible explanation
for uh they're being waved through with
little more than their own word for who
they are and what their birth date
is um okay so you've got this div
diverse migration and then you've got
this other migration and everything is
flipped on its head so do you want to
show a picture from uh the San vente
Camp so here these folks are just
outside the San vente Camp that's why I
can take this picture of them they're uh
all Chinese you're not allowed to
photograph in the San vente Camp uh
absolutely forbidden I took this I
literally put my camera up to a chain
Ling fence and I did so in a place where
there was something blocking the view of
the border security the centa front
officer that it wouldn't be seen that I
was taking the
picture um but in any case this is a
camp that is almost entirely
Chinese uh in
origin these people largely come a
different route they skip most of the
Peril of the Darian Gap by traveling by
boat we are not allowed into the camp
the migrants themselves are utterly
unwilling to have a conversation though
it is clear that there are those among
them who speak English they pretend not
to they
um there is just a
hostility um when one tries to interact
and I also had the sense this is
obviously not something I can be certain
of but I had the sense that after trying
to
interact that uh there were a couple of
individuals who became very interested
in figuring out who we were and what we
were trying to discover that that is to
say ostensible migrants who acted in a
way as if they were part of an
intelligence gathering uh operation I
can't say for sure that that's what I
saw but wow did it feel like it um Z you
want worth noting I'm put this picture
up now this Camp is entirely synthetic
there was no Village there before it's a
rectangle it's a fenced in rectangle
guarded by cifr which is the the Border
Authority in Panama and put together
largely by it's not a village that
turned into a migration Camp right in
fact it's built of different stuff too
it's built of shipping containers which
are I don't know that it means anything
but apparently Chinese and origin um but
anyway it it is it is a synthetic Camp
uh surrounded by a fence guarded by cifr
who does not allow pictures and does not
allow you in um Zach has a picture here
of a patch and this is
interesting um a CIF front guard was
wearing this patch we did not want to be
photographed but this says Daran
no it means it's not a root so even it's
a jungle It's a Jungle even people in
Panama who are charged with
administering a camp like this are not
happy about what's taking place I I
don't you know
this border uh the center Front guard
doesn't speak for everybody but there
was certainly a widespread sentiment
that this was not good for Panama um but
in any case the the hypothesis that I
want to put
forward is that the economic migration
that is so evident that you saw at the
first
Camp is
actually cloaking this second migration
which is traveling a different route
which is housed separately and which on
the ground has an absolutely distinct
character and is treated in the inverse
way by the authorities they don't want
it observed they can't prevent you from
seeing it from the edge of the camp but
they do not want you getting any deeper
into the thing they don't want you
photographing it and it's not obvious
why they would have a different policy
in fact the opposite policy as they did
in the main migration so anyway the
hypothesis that I want to put on the
table and I'm not saying that I I
necessarily believe that this is true
but I do believe it is plausible is that
the economic migration out of South
America is cloaking a migration of
largely military age Chinese migrants
who are motivated by something distinct
from they're not fleeing the CCP it's
not obvious that they are uh concerned
about the view of the CCP it appears
that they are actually facilitated by
the they've left China with the
knowledge of the CCP and that they have
joined this migration which we now try
to talk about as one thing but if it's
two things that will confuse
things so just want to add go ahead uh
you just just a point of clarification
you said uh you kind of glossed over you
said military age
people uh the demographics I mean I'm
interested in the direct comparison of
the demographics that you were observing
not in terms of racial identity you've
already gone over that um but age
distribution and families and stuff um
at the let's just call them like the
economic migrants camps versus um s
vente the synthetic rectangular Camp
mostly filled with Chinese people um I
will say the one one of the pictures
that we saw there from San vente there
was a woman yep um masked of course um
but I'm I'm curious about um I mean I
you've you've implied that there's a
demographic difference but let's start
by um I want to ask you the what you
know how many families did you see at
the camps that looked like economic
migrant camps that have um shown up in
places where there already Villages uh
and where you are allowed to walk in
Freely and where the people the migrants
themselves are actually willing to talk
to you um families are all over the
place um there are tragedies born of
this there are yeah uh mothers walking
out of the Jungle without their children
and children walking out of the Jungle
without their mothers um and that's not
how they walked in right um so it is a
dire situation and I I will just say for
those who aren't experienced in a
habitat like this part of the problem
with it is that it takes an injury that
would mean almost nothing if it happened
to you a sprained ankle can become fatal
in an environment where you need to get
through in a short period of time right
where you're trying where the where the
mud I mean I I've been in the dairy end
once but you know haven't been in the in
the jungle of the Der end this this
deeply um but in general in neotropical
lowland forests the mud can be so thick
so deep that you really need Not Just
Fitness but strength in order to get
through it yeah you it's a it's a slog a
SL right and you know the the Darion is
worse than many of the places that you
and I have been because it has some
altitude to it right um and so not only
are you dealing and you're talking about
relief like up and down you're going up
and down it's not it's not just all at
altitude the cordier the mountain range
that uh runs from the Continental Divide
down into South America runs through the
Darion and they have to cross it and so
it's not as high as it would be in the
US but imagine it in super slippery
conditions where thousands of people
have struggled their way up some muddy
Hill right it's just going to be you
know it's it's terribly slippery so it's
also true that um any any abrasion any
cut any any break in the barrier uh that
your body has which is your skin uh will
take forever to heal and you're in a
place where there are many more
pathogens um such that um you know a
very minor abrasion can become a very
major issue uh at least in the low ons
less so the higher up you are yeah but
there's also the added uh you've got
people from all over the world and so
mystery illnesses are also a feature of
people are arriving with some pathogens
right and you know it can be chalera
which again if you're a first world
denisen you know callar is not a big
deal it's treatable but if you get you
need access to fresh water or else Cola
and then you need uh you need to be
treated with antibiotics if you get it
um so anyway yes all of these things
that would be minor for us are not minor
in this context at all they just all
compound each other um one thing at the
at the camp you mentioned
canano um I believe it was a couple
migrants that I talked to and they had
come a shorter route it was somehow they
had arrived after a two-day Tri through
Darion um as opposed to five or six days
which lots of people were doing they
said that these were young men and they
were shocked that the families that had
made it through with them had made it
okay um they were okay they were torn up
but fine but they were very surprised
and they're and they're it's it's it's
these things that they're reporting um
the difficulty of the terrain and the
depth of the mud and the fact that
wounds don't heal and the bandits
they're being Bandit they're being
robbed and they're being robbed by other
migrants tragically they are being
robbed by indigenous people you imagine
you have all of these desperate people
who've taken whatever possessions
they've got migrating through and so
it's turning people who would not
ordinarily be interested in robbing
anybody the problem
is um it it's just a very perilous
situation and uh it's a tragedy in many
dimensions so I will say I asked exactly
that question to at a different camp but
to a couple migrants Venezuelan migrants
um I said what was the most dangerous
piece of the truck and they said without
a doubt uh lva the Jungle the forest um
even though guess that can mean a number
of things but even though there was a
huge amount of danger from Bandits and
other people and so one you know one
thing that that we know that you know
this is one of this is one of the things
that I used to really try to bring home
to students before I would start study
AB broad trips was I you know I know
you're worried about the charismatic
stuff you're worried about the big cats
and the snakes and there are big cats
and there are snakes that can do you
harm but it's the water and it's the
tree falls it's the stuff you're not
expecting and you know in longer term
you know I was taking them into field
stations which were rustic but they were
field stations we had plenty of fresh
water and we had first aid kits and we
had a medic and and such um but it's you
know things like suddenly the water is
rising and there's nowhere to go yep uh
and uh the wind has kicked up and a
storm has come in and suddenly there's
cracks all over the place and you don't
know where the tree is coming from when
it comes at you because it's falling y
um those are those are those are the
ways that people um get felled by lva by
the forest not nearly as often by a
Viper certainly not nearly as often by
an anaconda and definitely not nearly as
often as by a big cat and I think the
wildlife is pretty much gone from it's
probably hunted out it's gone from the
route yeah um Darion is huge and uh
presum
but story for another day but it may be
targeted for liquidation which will
destroy everything and even just putting
a road through it will do that too
slower but it will happen um but in any
case okay so um families are somehow
making this track and some members of
some families don't make it because it's
it's beyond arduous um and yeah still on
the other end at the at the northern
edge of the Gap um where um what you're
calling economic migrants are gathering
in cap uh camps like something Meo Canan
mrio Canan Meo um you have people of all
ages um families with young kids elderly
people not so much um some uh I would
say in retrospect I I wish I had thought
of it more carefully on the ground but
in retrospect the demographics of the
mass migration are about what you would
expect you know no I I I don't know what
to expect well you don't have the oldest
old okay right there are people who just
simply couldn't possibly make it lots of
people we did see old people who had
come through and in fact we talked to
many migrants who talked about the
families that they were traveling with
and the families were right there right
these people are so three generations
not uncommon three generations not
uncommon at all in fact common yep um
but of course three generations uh when
your generation time May be 20 years um
could be you know people might not even
be 50 yeah right that's true but there
were some there were some 60s maybe some
7s but anyway it it looked natural um in
the Chinese camp and again this is my
memory so now by comparison the
demographics going on at uh San vente
the camp that you describe as synthetic
it's rectangular uh it is being run by
the which is a sub agency of the UN this
is not where a village was there are no
villagers in involved in maintaining it
and you're not allowed in and there's an
era of secrecy you're not allowed in
you're not allowed to photograph and the
people don't want to talk to you and
there's a line of buses at the edge of
it we did actually not see anybody leave
from it but there's a line of buses
waiting for people to board to go north
you want to show and where those what
and so I'll have the same question for
you about those buses as I did about the
other ones um those look like um
potentially very fancy Latin American
buses or something more than that do we
know what funds these no idea okay no
idea and and it could be it could be
organic but nonetheless it is a measure
of the ex the flow through right you
have these I mean just to you also said
that many of those the immigrants at San
vente who are almost entirely Chinese
are coming in by boat rather than doing
the Sala the forest Crossing um so they
um are likely not to have been robbed so
they still have money so they can afford
to continue nor not only that but they
have been through they were just go
through a shorter route to there they go
through a minimal route and there's
actually we don't have it to show but um
there is a Chinese and origin uh Cartoon
that shows the route and it shows them
on boat bypassing most of the deran but
okay so you've got this second migration
people are not forthcoming you've asked
about the demographics I do not remember
seeing children there I'm not saying it
was zero and you weren't allowed to walk
inside right abely absolutely who knows
what you know there's there's sampling
eror it could be that just from the
angle I was standing that it looked
different than it actually was but my
sense was there were women but they were
they were a was even sex ratio not an
even sex at the other camps it was an
even sex Ratio or still bias towards I
if I think back I don't see any any bias
maybe there is but I didn't see it at
the among the economic what you're
calling the economic migrants it looked
like a
relatively um non select cross-section
of society missing the eldest and the
most infirm whereas and missing tiny
infants which I'm not saying weren't
there but I didn't didn't see them fair
enough whereas at uh the camp that I
don't think we've named um what this is
as opposed the economic migrants which
is almost entirely um Chinese people
you're saying um the sex ratio is widely
skewed there are women but the sex ratio
is wildly skewed and you were seeing
neither children nor old people yeah and
and
however caveat um you had less access to
those people and that camp and therefore
it's possible you know all the children
were on the inside or something like but
that's not usually the way of children
in such places they' be running around
there'd be some evidence of right um so
this raises a question
and I do think it makes sense for people
to go check out the Chris Martinson
discussion but you can find at our
locals yeah because in fact you you
watch watch this idea Dawn in real time
right so what what I realized in talking
to Chris you may remember many years ago
when we were at Evergreen I wrote a
piece which I was experimenting with a
WordPress site and I wrote a piece that
I published on it um I remember it was I
think green and it had a picture of an
ardvar which was an inside inside joke
um we can talk about the oke joke
another time but you probably should but
anyway the point was that there is an
odd Paradox with the Chinese one child
policy um and that Paradox has to do
with the work of a guy named Ronald
Fischer who's an evolutionary biologist
who wasn't talking about people at all
but what Ronald Fischer came up with
famously one of the the anchor points of
evolutionary biology is the basis of sex
ratio Theory and it's pretty simple what
he said was that although a male in many
species can produce vastly more
offspring than a female there is no
advantage to being male or female
because the average number of Offspring
tends to be the same for every male who
over produces offspring above the
average there are losers who
underperform and so at the population
level there's not an advantage and
therefore you expect as the as you get a
skew in a population towards one sex the
other that those parents who produce the
sex that is now limiting will win um
because um their children will be more
more needed in the population and that's
the key thing is to the extent that a
population has a bias there is an
advantage to producing whatever is rare
so I applied that to China and I said
why doesn't this work here put yourself
in the mind of a Chinese couple that is
going to produce one
child if you produce a male there's a
pretty good likelihood that male never
finds a mate
and that's a problem you produce a
female not only is that child going to
find a mate but they can marry up
because the point is males need mates
and so a female uh is in a very good
position in the reproductive hierarchy
to find uh a mate who with good
prospects or whatever is desirable and
frankly uh and I don't remember if you
wrote this into that piece but uh
societies can recover from a shortage of
uh males much much more easily than they
can recover from a shortage of females
both because uh there's a long history
of societies having to do that in times
of war and because the nature of the
Sexes is that uh one male can um can
make pregnant many many females and um
gestation and lactation being what it is
and absolutely mandatory until very
modern technology has uh rendered some
of these things somewhat um outsourced
capable possible uh it just takes a long
time for any woman to produce um more
than one kid yep so the upshot of that
piece from many years ago was there's
something odd about the fact that in the
context of a sex biased population that
it does not naturally correct by the
logic of Ronald Fischer's sex ratio
Theory and what I hypothesized then was
that there was a second adaptive
mechanism that overrides this in the
case that a population needs an army
that effectively overproducing males
naturally predisposes a society
towards um confronting
neighbors and that that would be a
reason that a society would have a
paradoxical bias in favor of the already
Surplus sex if it was males now I
remember thinking that and spooking
myself because of the implications of a
Nation as large as China over producing
males and therefore producing something
that looked an awful lot like an army
and then I let it go because I didn't
see the prediction of that hypothesis
manifest in the world I did not see
China invading neighbor states with its
Surplus males and so uh I wouldn't say
it was falsified but it became less and
less a feature of my thinking because
the evidence just didn't suggest that it
had been correct in seeing what's going
on in the Darion of Panama I now think
maybe it was
correct the hypothesis is that those
males who seem to be the bulk of the
people moving through these camps might
plausibly be uh a fighting force that is
being moved through an open border uh
that is as far as I'm concerned without
rational explanation and that they are
starting in the Darion of Panama
because that provides an explanation
which distracts from the real
one by joining that provides cover yeah
that because there's already there is
there is an
organic there are several really organic
economic migrations happening already uh
being funneled through this narrow point
between the two Americas uh and heading
north and everyone can point to real
economic and political upheaval
everywhere in the world practically uh
and we and we and we know that the
southern border has been a point of
contention forever yeah and so so
there's there's already real stuff going
on and uh and it would be easy it would
be an easy place to have other things
start to happen that get passed off as
more of the same exactly and for people
who are our age we remember similar
migrations from Central America that had
just well we grew up in La so you know
we're close enough to the Border uh that
you know we heard from we heard from
people at various moments about oh yes
you know there is there is less there is
more they're trying to cut you know shut
down immigration at the border uh and uh
you know it's less right near the coast
um the California border with Mexico is
not nearly so uh political as uh in
Texas for instance or farther Inland
even in in the California border but um
but it's always fraught well it's always
fraught but let's just say there
was most of our childhoods there was an
influx of central Americans they were
famously hardworking and entrepreneurial
doesn't mean that bad folks didn't get
through occasionally but in general you
know the sense of people who interacted
with that migration because of where
they live LA's economy would have fallen
apart without uh the Mexican and Central
American immigrants right so anyway that
the familiarity of that pattern and the
frankly not very threatening nature of
that migration doesn't mean it was
legitimate it doesn't mean that
Americans didn't pay a price for the
fact that lots of folks were taking jobs
that were therefore not available for
Americans but the Scuttle butt when we
were kids was that they're taking jobs
that most Americans wouldn't want and so
anyway it was uh cryptically understood
to be a uh a mutualism yeah I mean the
the whole the whole migrant labor thing
um you know which which then became
politicized in a different regard with
regard to getting you know labor labor
unionization I guess of of the labor
movement but um you know having people
moving up and down the west coast to to
pursue what needs to be picked out of
you know is it strawberries now is it
strawberries in the Central Valley of
California is it apples in Washington
you know what what needs to be picked
now these are people without um any
security and without promise that
they'll be work next year although if
the climate continues and the apples
grow yep you show up next year and we'll
pay you again but the conditions might
be a little worse and we might not give
you what you came to expect this year um
but uh if those same Farms the same um
Farms with orchards had tried to hire uh
Americans American Born Americans uh
they wouldn't have been able to make a
profit um because they would have had to
pay those people too much yep so I don't
think our current economic circumstances
mirror the circumstances of the 70s and
80s yeah um I think this is a very
different environment where Americans
are struggling at a level that is uh new
and unfamiliar um I thought the economy
was fine yeah I've heard that um I have
not noticed it um but in any
case there is a migration it seems to be
motivated by Economic Opportunity the
sheer number number of people who is
migrating through Central America into
the US is so large that it is impossible
to imagine that this is not going to be
um hugely disruptive to the entire
economic environment it is not clear
what these people are going to do upon
arriving there are very frightening
possibilities that these people are
being allowed to to move across our
Southern border because somebody has
planed
um to utilize them in one way or another
and that is a frightening prospect on
its own but even if that were not true
and the simple answer is that they are
supposed to find something productive to
do in the US there are so many of them
and there are so many Americans who
already don't have something productive
to do that this can't
possibly uh not be viewed as a threat to
vulnerable American citizens and why our
federal government would be so uh
unconcerned maybe they're this week
becoming embarrassed enough that they
have to pretend to be concerned but they
clearly haven't been concerned um that
is a paradox of its own right that just
seems shocking um the most basic duty of
the federal government is you know to
protect the Integrity of the country
from things that threaten it including a
mass migration of desperate people um so
um I hear a couple of embedded
hypotheses or rather yeah embedded with
one another within one another um the
the one from a couple of decades ago
that you hypothesized then uh was it the
one child policy uh whether by whether
intentionally or not uh will serve to
create a a standing army that will then
be you know ready and uh furthermore you
have a hypothesis that having seen what
you have just seen in Panama a week or
so ago um that it feels that it feels
like there are two migrations happening
and that one of them is indeed a
primarily Chinese migration of primarily
military-aged people of primarily men uh
who are unforthcoming about what they
are doing in contrast to every other
person we met and um and everything
indeed about uh that migration is
different in some way uh and that that
is uh that is hard to point to because
if you're just at the border of you know
Texas in Mexico seeing people come
across you know who everyone looks the
same I mean everyone it's in fact it's a
very very diverse group of group of
migrants but you can't tell the
difference at that point as as you can
in the dairy end because the camps look
different the way they're being treated
is different the way uh the secrecy is
different everything is different right
um but once you combine everyone later
on once it gets funneled once everyone
gets funneled together at The Crossings
it's hard to tell
um what might be an alternative
explanation what might an alternative
hypothesis be to explain not the one
child policy what was that about but to
explain what you saw what you actually
saw in Panama with these different kinds
of camps these different demographic
makeups the different secrecy the
different treatment Etc uh another
explanation would be
that
either with a wink from the Chinese
Communist party
or evading its surveillance that people
fleeing China were looking for
opportunity in the US and that because
they have lived under a totalitarian
regime their reluctance to talk is a
reflex based on having been surveilled
not knowing that explains a tiny piece
of the difference doesn't explain the
disparity and wealth and organization
and resources that seem to be coming not
just from the people but also from the
UN no it could be it could it could I
don't think it does because fine but
like I I want to hear an alternative
hypothesis sure no I think it's I think
it's a good exercise and it may well be
but the fact of Chinese culture being
being remote from not all but most of
the other cultures that are migrating
might mean that just from the point of
view of delivering services to Chinese
people it might be easier to organize
them if there was a large number of them
China's a large Source population large
number of migrants motivated by
something like Economic Opportunity or
fleeing oppression or whatever it was
they might end up in Panama they might
how many camps did you see just no we
saw three camps and what was the which
in which style was the third camp that
you haven't yet talked about third Camp
was actually a different style but in
terms of the demographics it was very
much like the Canan mrio Camp economic
migrants economic migrants in terms of
age structure uh ethnicity um had
appeared to have sprung up organically
near a village such as the villagers
were helping to run it even though they
would rather that the immigrants not be
there Absol and our fre fre
to talk to people uh photograph it all
of that matched the Canan M Brio camp
and not the San vente Camp not quite
there it was a combination that camp
that we saw the second camp that we saw
um mostly matched Canan MBO but there
was a section of it that we weren't
allowed into that was like an organized
set of buildings for migrants put
together by I so we didn't see that part
of it but it was mostly like the first
organic Camp okay Dem May been a piece
of it that we didn't get into which I
there was see but um in terms of the
demographics it's not that there was a
huge population same frankly I'd be
surprised if you were allowed to roam
freely through all parts of any camp
like that
doesn't why would you be able to I mean
that was that was the case in uh in
Canan M but anyway let's let's finish
out the hypothesis the hypothesis would
be that the origin story of the Chinese
migrants is very different their
economic status their uh the journey
obviously is very different from China
than it would be from Venezuela um
although equally different from
Venezuela as from Yemen or Afghanistan
both of whom you saw me you know
immigrants from agreed but it might be
that economically I mean really money
allows you to skip the most treacherous
parts of the Darian so the Chinese
migrants maybe because of economies of
scale because there are lots of them and
they can arrange boat travel I don't
know something
um but you could imagine a different
story allows a better route economies of
scale is actually interesting
possibility here yeah right yeah it is
not
clear why you would join in
Panama what do you mean why you would
join in Panama why you would join what
in Panama if you can skip the Darion by
boat it is not obvious why why why do
you land in in still in the Daran right
you've got a lot tring to do to get into
the US
yeah although so I um as you know I did
a field season on the Caribbean coast of
um of Costa Rica just and then you know
we've spent time and I also did study
abroad on the kban coast of Panama very
near there in bcus um but the season
that I was down in tanka in uh in Costa
Rica um what I was hearing it was the
offseason for surfing and therefore it
was the offseason for cocaine and that
the boats that were coming this would
this would have been mid 990s um the
drug boats that were coming up from
South America mostly from Colombia um
during the season when there were lots
of tourists which in that part of Costa
Rica meant Surfers W were in town um the
boats would always stop and and drop to
their um to their local dealers and then
there would be basically a Coke infused
economy uh for for the I don't remember
how much of the year um that um that it
happened and but those boats had a hard
time the the the the story and this is
you know this is decades ago and it was
hearsay um but I I was I was living
there in a time when um when it wasn't
surf season and therefore it wasn't Coke
season it was actually dangerous because
um there was um there was still some
coke around and the dealers had no one
to sell it to and so they were coked up
and they were not making any money and
they were going on occasional shooting
spree and sometimes they went into the
forest and otherwise I was the only
person hanging out in the forest cuz I
was there to study poison frogs and um
the people would occasionally you know
band together the people of the town
would pan together and Chase the drug
dealers out into the forest and then
they'd be you know coked up in the
forest with guns um and everyone was
sort of waiting for these Coke boats to
come back but during a lot of times of
the year they couldn't um was the story
that that was basically for boats of a
certain size it wasn't going to work
very well so I you know yeah I'm not I'm
not arguing that there's obvious boat
route but the point is Panama is a funny
Place Panama does not have the uh lack
of a Visa requirement that Ecuador does
so there's something about joining a
migration in Panama that's funny but
didn't you say that they I mean they had
they they the expectation was had come
into Ecuador and had just taken the boat
the short distance to evade the Gap it
wasn't that they they flew into Panama
didn't fly to the Darion Gap that's true
so I I have important information here
no one is getting around the daring Gap
they are getting to depending on how
much money they have to spend they're
taking boats from a Colombian uh town to
various different Colombian towns no one
is getting past the Panamanian border on
boats I'm not going to say no one but
the route the most people are taking
including the Chinese migrants the
Chinese are paying more to go further
but there are like three different towns
up passing and they're also apparently
using things like horses there's
mechanisms that are
no one's even getting into Panama
they're staying behind the Colombian
border and then walking through the Der
and everyone that we saw was doing that
even if they're taking advantage of
horses or different things to make it
easier they're all going through and
that's I mean that that that actually
that that that fits with the story that
a lot of the Jungle that you would have
to miss would be in Colombia that you
can take boats a short distance but um
but you can't just cross the um the
Border by sea into Panama because Panama
has a long history of watching out for
these boats um that the it was drug
boats maybe it still is but now it's
migrant boats right yeah so that that
that all that fits fits is yeah I mean
there's still something there's still
there's something odd about the whole
thing right you've got a migration which
is unnecessary if we're going to allow
people
in it's odd to make them walk through
all of Central America or take buses or
anything else yeah right yeah so anyway
there is a paradox there yeah how
exactly it works so but so the the
alternative hypothesis I here has
something to do with um
uh there's more Chinese migrants um who
you know maybe because they're coming
from a long longer ways away they either
already knew each other or have had time
to know each other um they um they don't
share a language with any of the other
migrants which would also be the true
for the Afghans and the yemenis but you
know not for like the Venezuelans versus
the Colombians versus there some
critical mass of people some critical
mass of people they share a language
they share a culture they share the
journey up until this point uh and um
economies of scale being what they are
they can join forces um but but that
still doesn't explain at you know unless
the San Venta camp that you saw is was
an outlier it was was like that's the
only camp that looks like that and
that's the one you saw like why is that
one in the middle of nowhere not organic
um totally synthetic totally rectangular
as opposed to having grown up from um
from where people you know emerg from
the forest bed draggled and tired and
why is there a long line of buses there
waiting maybe that's because of the
relative wealth of the Chinese um but
there's there's still a piece that feels
like
that the only alternative hypothesis so
far that we've got on the
table the evidence that you saw doesn't
explain it as well yeah that's the
problem with it um I would also say
there's a part that
um is just a feeling sure the Y
hostility
I I know what it's like from the
migrants from the migrants I know what
it's like when somebody does not feel at
Liberty to talk they want to talk but
they don't feel that it is safe that is
very different than what we felt these
were people who viewed us
dimly they did not want to talk because
it makes no sense to share information
with us right it's all downside that's
what it felt like so there's that
um yeah and you know I I also just can't
explain which is rare like we've run
into that sometimes in our travels but
usually if you if you have an openness
to you and make some attempt at
understanding where you are and the
culture you're in and the language and
just you don't need to be anywhere close
to fluent but just like make some
attempt to be like hi I'm a human being
you are too I'm really interested in the
fact that I'm in your home
and I want to know more about it almost
everyone has an interest in that yeah
even more imagine that you had decided
to up and leave your home culture and
you were going to America and Americans
show up in Panama interested in your
story it is not a slam dunk that you
would be anything other than fascinated
by this first tast of culture concerned
at first this isn't what it appears like
oh what are you know what what is this
are you are you the feds whatever
but if not that then interested I would
I mean and we we clearly weren't I mean
just our style of dress and all would
have suggested otherwise so anyway the
thing did feel very off um
and in any
case uh yes multiple embedded hypotheses
a kind of Trojan migration is one of
them that there's a natural organic uh
economic migration and then there's some
other migration traveling within it and
here in the US the point is well what do
you think of the
migrants like well which migrants you
know yeah um that's that's it that's
that's the punchline right like what
what do you think of what's going on at
the border yeah what do you think of the
migrants what do you think of what's
going on at the border I think there are
a lot of things going on at the border
yeah I think there's more than one thing
going on the border and my you know I'm
against all of it because I'm an
American Amer and I know that you it's
one thing for a small number of people
to enter the country it's another thing
for hundreds of thousands possibly
millions ofer of new Americans to arrive
or de facto Americans right the point is
was our economy humming along so well
that it can just simply absorb that
number of people and not directly Rob
the people who are struggling in our
economy already no way so I'm against it
for that reason but I'm absolutely
compassionate with respect to the fact
that these people are fleeing something
real right and you know I'm I'm as an
American I'm honored that they would
think that America was still a good
place to go as we're watching it
collapse you know it's interesting that
a lot of people still view it in uh
terms that I think frankly probably need
an update but um but anyway I'm against
that at one level but it's all human and
then there's a question of did our
enemies figure something out about this
migration either as an opportunity or
did they seed it through the internet
AAL Community right in order to cloak
what they're up to you know again it's a
hypothesis but it's one that we really
need to think carefully about um and I
would just say one last thing there's
one more hypothesis related to this
maybe there are two but there's one that
I want to put on the table
here when I did my uh episode with the
folks from the US military who had been
thrown whistle threatened right um two
episodes right you spoke to several
people in two different episodes about
the effects of the vaccine mandates had
on them right some of these people had
been driven out and some of them were
fighting to maintain their careers but
in any case um this looked hostile to
American interests to take some of our
best people and drive them out because
they were uh reluctant about vaccines
that frankly a reasonable person had
every reason to be reluctant about and I
said two things at the time one is I
said you know what that is going to
leave behind a force that is compliant
to immoral orders and that's
frightening but
two this one way that this could come
about is that somebody could have
noticed our pay forplay political
system and instead of corrupting it for
some corporate interest that was bad for
Americans they could have corrupted it
for one of our International antagonist
interests and just basically
induced us to harm ourselves right
vaccinating our entire military right
that wasn't a good idea yeah there was
no defense for that these were in
general healthier than average Americans
younger than average Americans these
were not people jeopardized by covid and
giving them something even if it had
shown itself to be perfectly harmless in
the trials we nobody knew what the
long-term impact was that was a dumb
thing to do why would we do a dumb thing
like that right it's not inobvious that
there's a risk there and uh so anyway
the hypothesis I put on the table then
was that if you have a corrupt political
system where it does the bidding of
whoever ponies up the the dough then
what's to stop our enemies from ponying
up the dough right and if you think
there is something to stop them like we
have laws against that um then the point
is okay well where are the court cases
that indicate that those laws have been
applied in a way that has frustrated the
enemies that have undoubtedly tried it
yeah and if those court cases don't
exist then my contention is you'd be a
fool to think this never happened and we
don't know what effect it has but
anytime we you know Savage ourselves we
should ask ourselves the question of did
we do it because we were confused or did
we do it because we were induced to do
it um so anyway another hypothesis
indeed um did you want to tie this into
to igg4 at all or or do you want to save
that let us save that until next week
okay um people who are interested in
diving into that discussion uh should
check out the locals chat with um with
Chris Martinson good uh there's some
stuff on it there and then we can do a
deeper dive next
week all right uh so that's um that was
a good solid conversation already um I
got a couple little things but did you
also want to do a big conversation about
a totally different topic right now um
no I think I think we should hold that
one as well okay I just won't even say
the noun then okay yeah we're g to save
that okay so
um we could talk for a while about these
things that I want to talk about here
but probably better not to because
we'll disgust everyone oh no yeah okay
so something cool something
grotesque um the cool thing is
uh here we
have this is just the science news uh
version of some new research giving
birth gives birth to neurons in mice
pregnancy results and new neurons that
support recognition of pups uh so
neurogenesis um new new neurons um don't
happen very often in in the adult brain
or the adult uh central nervous system
in mammals and verteb it's more
generally uh so whenever you find
neurogenesis evidence of neurogenesis
that is um the proliferation
proliferation of actually new neurons
not just new connections um you know the
new we we do form new connections all
the time um but actually new neurons is
is uh pretty rare and there's and this
is you know this is mice um we don't we
don't know for humans but um there's
this this cool research uh and actually
just if I can have my screen back for a
moment I'll just show the actual um the
actual paper um I don't know why it's
not going full screen for me um so
here's the here's the original research
um pregnancy responsive pools of adult
neural stem cells for transient
neurogenesis and mothers note transient
um and so what they think what what
these researchers think is going on is
that um neurogenesis late in pregnancy
in the AL Factory bulb and
lobe yeah exactly for these mammals
which like most M the vast majority of
mammals primates being a notable
exception are all Factory forward you
can see you can't see in the background
our dog moving around with her snout
like you know you know dogs you know
mammals we've all got big noses with
primates being an exception and Alf
faction is a big part of um of what we
do in order to make sense of our world
and in fact blessed are the big noses
are the big noses for they shall smell
the world um and in fact in Prime
um the Primitive olfactory bulb and lobe
have become um the forbrain that is
mostly associated with um scenario
building and memory so you know thinking
both backwards and forwards in time uh
it's part of why it's part of why we we
are so good at those things is that
we've taken over our primitively smell
focused um part of the brain and also
part of why probably um smells evoke
memories so effectively for people but
um anyway these in these mice um late
pregnancy
in late pregnancy mothers have
neurogenesis in their refactory regions
and uh the thought is the hypothesis is
um to explain the finding that there is
neurogenesis late in pregnancy um is
that this helps them um immediately um
recognize and then remember what their
pups smell like so that they will have
um kin recognition through Al faction
very effectively through the period of
time when they will be lactating and um
actively mothering their pups pups I
don't know if pups is the right word for
a good one yeah yeah um yeah that's
super interesting isn't it um so you
would extrapolate from this I would say
it's much less likely in humans or even
primates that it would be in the old
factory lobe but it's not unlikely that
there is a parallel process or it might
be and given that thefactory lobe now is
mostly about memory and and scenario
building again you know thinking through
time yeah both backwards and forwards um
and given that we have the longest
childhoods of any organisms on on the
planet relative to lifespan um you know
making being really clear about this
this is mine like this everything about
this baby I want to know everything and
never
forget right now there's less of an
issue with respect to recognizing
especially as you get out towards humans
there's much less of an a uh an
ambiguity um yeah that's true it's
actually it raises a question about
other creatures where there's even more
of an ambiguity yeah so you bats like
bats interesting bats in a colony of
hundreds of thousands or millions of
animals um the ability to recognize
one's own offspring is known but how
does it work yes and you might see this
even more extensively there yeah now
actually um you can put this up I'm not
going to explain the whole um image so
this is just from the um yeah this is
just from the science news report this
is not from the original article but
they have little schematic um in which
you know here's the brain here's the mom
brain going oh I know you're mine and
you're mine you're mine you're mine and
you can see you know this is like is the
case in most uh most mammals it's a it's
a clutch it's a it's a litter right
there's there's a a bunch of babies but
mice don't tend to I think have do
Colony breeding or do they well
but well two things yeah
one it is uh this would be I this is a
hypoth tot know where you're going
hypothesis to put on the table but I
don't believe it likely just think it's
plausible Yep this could be an effect of
the captive breeding colonies right
which Al because they are they are
Colony breed they are um be curious I
don't know exactly how it's done but
it's possible that this is a pH
neurogenesis is such a big leap if that
wasn't happening at all no no no no no I
I I I see that sort of trigger
neurogenesis is a thing there's some
mechanism um it could be triggered by a
powerful evolutionary Force the same way
the elongation of mouse tiir was again I
don't think this is likely but possible
Right but here's the thing that I think
this actually
predicts
cuckoldry in
rodents um this would be evolve this
would be a better prediction if it's if
the neurogenesis lat in pregnancy is
only in
rodents um well let's put it this way
the
best prediction would be that this
pattern of neurogenesis would be present
where cuckoldry had been a significant
evolutionary force and that this had
been an evolved response to it yeah so
this is this is um moms really want to
know who their kids are and I guess
um part of part of what this is going to
be a response to is moms are going to
have to go out and forage forage right
and so
um
you know if they have to leave their
kids Behind either with no caretaker at
all or with a dad if they're monogamous
or with a helper at the nest um then
when they come back they want to know
for sure um who they're nursing who
they're letting latch on well but again
not a big deal if youve if you know
because they're in some you know pocket
in a log and there's nobody else there
but if there are other individuals that
are dropping uh babies off because it's
right a bargain yep then uh so anyway um
let's just leave that as a prediction if
we see a paper that says cuckle and I
mean maybe there are such papers I don't
know but um if there aren't and we see
one then we'll have a good cohesive
story as to why this would evolve yeah
um and I'd love to see
um I'd love to know what's going on with
primates if we have neurogenesis and
pregnancy and primates and and where and
yeah I mean I bet I bet you do um but I
bet you it's uh let's see we can predict
where it
be well I mean the where in the brain
you know a a primates have taken over so
much of the the historically the
primitively old factory brain for um
basically our cortex uh so I don't know
that thinking through exactly where in
the brain it's going to be is going to
be all that useful yeah and and as you
pointed out at the beginning it might be
done through dendritic growth rather
than neurogenesis right okay so that's
cool uh the next thing is not oh no um
it
seemed okay um it's the diaper
Spa excuse me
yeah um so we have our our we have Libs
of Tik Tock and our friend Holly to
thank for bringing this to my attention
but um boston.com website also ran a
piece on it um
and here let's just start there you can
show my screen what's a diaper Spa
writes boston.com
what's a diaper spa and why is it
raising eyebrows in New
Hampshire people tend to fear anything
that they fail to comprehend said the
owner of the diaper Spa a new business
at stoking local
controversy a debate over a new Spa is
brewing in Southern New Hampshire where
some residents in Atkin Center taking a
stand against the diaper Spa a nursery
like business for adults who role play
as children and yes wear
diapers wait what according to its
website the diaper Spa is open to quote
all diaper wearing individuals who seek
acceptance respit and Care photos on the
Spa's page show a space decorated with
the soft Comforts of a nursery complete
with toys folded diapers and adult-sized
crib Dr Colleen Anne Murphy the Spa's
owner offers a range of services that
include virtual play dates at $200 an
hour as well as a $1,500 all day diaper
BNB experience that promises
rejuvenating pampering quote for the
little one inside of
you okay so if I can have my screen
back boston.com goes
on to say that there is a mom so also
the location it's not open yet the
location of this thing is right near a
park there's a mom in the local area
who's like I'm not going to take my kids
to that Park and actually I'm going to
set up a change.org
petition um saying actually please don't
give them a business license what what
the actual hell right and interestingly
the particulars of the change.org
petition um have now been resolved and
so it's been taken down like three days
after it went up but boston.com because
this is like this is very close to
Boston this is like this is going to be
something that uh the women who's
running this diaper spies hoping to get
the I don't know the diaper Elites from
Boston to go to um reports positively
about this diaper Spa thing and then
says about the mom who is concerned
about it that her opening up no don't
I'm looking for it don't don't show my
screen please um that her opening up a
uh the change.org bition is her doubling
down there it is Gallagher doubled down
on those concerns so we know the bias of
this boston.com
outfit but let's just take a look shall
we
at the website
itself okay uh so this is um from
Reflections okay nighttime Comfort a
guide to overnight diapering for
abdl's what you might ask is an abdl an
abdl is an adult baby diaper
lover for many adult baby diaper lovers
nighttime diapering is essential to
their lifestyle providing comfort and
security this blog post will explore
techniques and products that enhance the
nighttime diapering experience from
specific types to trusted Brands will
delve into creating a secure and
worry-free night okay I think we've had
enough I I spent a little bit of time
with this and I realized that I actually
was not controlling the look of disgust
on my face with just
every every moment of looking at this
site so there's obvious concerns about
um who the people are like the there's
there's the umbrella level concerns
about who the people are who would be
attracted to go to this thing and having
it next to a park and all of this and
there's been accusations of like these
people must be um you know pedophiles at
the very least they're they're mentally
ill why are we encouraging them all of
this let's let's be a little bit more
basic
even what
Society tells people that it's okay okay
to give up on what may be the very first
item of control that we gain over
ourselves this is the first thing that
humans learn how to do it is utterly
fundamental to being with other human
beings to being with
them in what world could you possibly
imagine that looking for care looking
for for comfort is to be
found by in your own pants
yeah I cannot believe that we are
here it
is the
natural there is a slippery slope that
involves attempting to police
people's um
meanness yeah yes so yes is is it good
to be mean no right but once you start
saying
well making fun of people is bad right
and you start policing the places where
it probably is just purely bad right the
point is you're opening the door to
saying well actually making fun of
people has no place right right and once
shame has no place right and the point
is as we make this point across many
many
domains if you have a doctor who thinks
pain is a malady rather than an
adaptation don't go to that doctor right
your pain is there to help guide you now
it may be that you have pain in a
phantom limb that's a problem that's not
helping you but in general if you're in
pain there's a reason and it's trying to
tell you something right same thing can
be said for unhappiness the same thing
can be said for shame and feeling
humiliated and the idea that we are
going to take away the feedbacks that
allow people to develop a proper sense
of what is reasonable right yes we have
people who are saying well why shouldn't
I be allowed to wear X Y and Z what is
the reason and the answer is it's not
you know chesterton's fence being what
it is the precautionary principle being
what it is there are lots of things that
a natural human society will train you
to that you will be better off for
having picked up the lesson and it
doesn't mean you won't have some moment
of profound embarrassment in you know
childhood or your teen years or
something but the point is that
embarrassment causes you to build the
circuit that prevents you from doing the
thing that is embarrassing you and so
there's some stuff you know this it's an
MD who started this thing and so of
course her credentials are the really
important thing here this is the first
MD Leed diaper Spa which suggests that
there are other diaper Spas oh my God
but okay yeah her
her weasel words to explain to the non
adult baby diaper loving public why this
is okay is well I was originally
interested in this because there are
people who uh for um like physical
injury reasons need to wear diapers as
adults they they're in continent there's
nothing to be done about
it how dare you conflate that with this
first of all like I am I imagine uh that
uh those people would really rather you
stay the hell away from them MH um but
from there she goes to so I got
interested in you know why people
sometimes feel they need feel that they
need to but I want but I want and I'm
not quoting her directly because I'm not
going to go back on the website right
now but um she she tries to make this
point that frankly sounds a lot like a
point you have made over in um
psychedelic space around not for
recreation um very entertaining very
interesting but um it's more than
Recreation and she tries to walk that
line here and say um we're not this is
not a spa for people who just like to
wear diapers this is a spa for people
who feel they need to wear
diapers and this is her her client her
imagined future clientele is mostly not
the people who actually really do and
also feel like having their nappies ch
Changed by a woman um this is this is
people who have decided just like the
vast majority of people who are claiming
to be trans this is a need if I don't
get this I will die if I don't get this
you are negating who I am what my
identity is I will not be allowed to go
I will not be able to go on this is that
same conflation where all you have to do
is say oh no this isn't something I want
this is something I need and suddenly
we're not allowed to say no suddenly as
soon as you change it from I want it to
I need it and there's been actually no
change at all in anything except the
word that you used now we aren't allowed
to shame we aren't allowed to critique
we aren't allowed to say actually that's
not okay get control of your bowels
already and figure out some other way to
explore who you
are it's going to be some version of mun
shaen syndrome right where the idea is
there's some category that we're going
to deem protected in which there's
something you can do that forces
somebody else to do something and for
whatever terrible reason you find that
gratifying yeah and I agree with you it
has a lot to do with uh
the
um confrontational version of trans
where people are y effectively daring
others to notice that they are not the
sex that they nominally are presenting
as yeah right so this is this is like
that
and it really I mean it just obviously
there was
a safety on the gun and we removed it
somewhere probably as a result of some
arguably Noble instinct to protect
somebody from something but it was at
the top of a slippery slope you know we
took away the the caution watch your
step slippery slope you know no
lifeguard whatever the sign said yeah
right and then the point is we've been
marched one step at a time to ever
stupider things that we are forbidden to
comment on forbidden to view as shameful
yeah and um you know I look at the end
of the day here's where we are we have
this
insanity if compassion is your thing
isn't it more compassionate to allow a
bit of teasing and mockery in order to
get people to correct their program so
that they don't need to go to a spa
where they can wear diapers right isn't
that mockery actually serving their
interests even though there may be a
moment of intense humiliation for them
that then causes them to realize oh this
is a program I really need to change
yeah right that's the compassionate
thing and you know I mean we've made
this point before but there is this
intense um fervor against bullying right
and look bullies suck there's no
question about it but if you make all if
you assume that all bullying comes from
bullies right then you're making a
mistake because in fact
people by revealing you know even the
people in your schoolyard are revealing
something about what others can see that
you don't necessarily know that they can
see and they are helping train you and
you know it's the same thing in a
scientific context your labmates are not
doing you a favor by telling you that
your work is awesome when it's not your
labmates are doing you a favor by
telling you hey that point is not
compelling here's what I see that argues
against it right and causing you yes in
that moment it may be very unpleasant to
face that question but you need somebody
to put you to that test so that at the
point that your work gets into the world
you're ready for it so I mean there's
there's three different manifestations
and I I I want us to be careful I know
you're not actually um synonymizing
these but it an uncareful listener might
imagine that you are saying that a
schoolyard bully is a scientific critic
is um someone who would shame those who
would like to um wear diapers and have
someone else clean up their feces um
the the scient the critique of science
which is utterly necessary for science
to actually do what science does uh is
uh works when um I I've done a piece of
research and I'm putting it um to I've
shared it with you and you say
oh I get that you like you've already
done the work and like and because
you're a field biologist you already
came home and like you can't really redo
this but I feel like there's a
methodological flaw so you don't
actually know what you think you
know sucks for me sucks for me a lot but
I need to know I mean it's not going to
go away and I need to not publish that
thinking that I didn't that I did know
something that I did demonstrate
something with the experiment that I did
that I actually didn't because I had not
yet seen that there was a methodological
flaw that is different
from the like canonical schoolyard bully
who goes who's weak you okay what's weak
about you you're um developmentally
delayed and that has you have no
responsibility for that whatsoever it's
nothing you did to yourself it's nothing
you asked for it's not you didn't come
to me asking for
critique you're a kid who's
developmentally delayed and frankly
everyone already knows that but everyone
was being
polite and trying to include you in the
things that you could be included in and
not drawing you into things until very
recently that you actually had no place
in because your developmental days means
that you can't actually um compete
equally with others in some Realms the
schoolyard bully goes I'm going to find
the weakness and I'm going to go after
the weakness and the weakness and the
weakness and it's immutable and it's
unchosen and it's
Uninvited uh and uh it persists even
after recognition maybe that's the
distinction right that the scientific
critique um you know you need to keep
hammering me if I say no it's fine like
I definitely know what I found and you
say well I know that your data say what
they say but given this flaw in the
experiment in the experiment your
methodology can't possibly have revealed
what you think it does so it doesn't
matter what your data say um they don't
they don't mean what you think you
actually do get to and I would ask that
you do keep hammering me on that until I
look until you figure out a way to say
it in a way that I can go like oh God
you're right damn it like right but the
the kid who's developmentally lay on the
playground um wasn't asking for it
doesn't need it isn't helped by it um
and so the bully doesn't actually have
any legitimate reason to keep on doing
that nor in fact did he have any reason
to start doing it in the first place
because it was some immutable
characteristic of some kid who um didn't
deserve to be picked on I think you have
all the pieces of the puzzle that we
need okay in in in that one is the bully
is lo is is loathsome when they pick on
somebody for something that isn't their
responsibility and they can't do
anything about yeah development
developmentally uh disabled kid is just
purely a victim and and the bully is a
nasty human being for choosing that
thing but I'm trying to draw a
distinction between bullying which is a
natural feature of childhood and a bully
who takes that on as their job and goes
around so we need like a we need a
different word or something we've talked
about the fact that very often the term
we have is applied to the malignant
version of something that has a normal
version that doesn't have a name right
so shaming does feel like this is part
this is this is part of right and you
know needling is this side of shaming
right shaming is more Barbed needling is
like hey we can see that thing that you
think we can't see you know um so I mean
guys do this all the freaking time right
right they do it all the freaking time
your best friends reveal the little
stuff that you know right and women do
it more cryptically much more
cryptically
they will support each when they should
because the point is then you don't
realize that you're on display and your
friends didn't you know your friends you
have toilet paper stuck to your shoe I
didn't tell you yeah that's terrible but
so okay so there's a difference between
picking on somebody for something they
can't change which has no potential
benefit and picking on somebody in some
way needling them or maybe slightly more
to get them to change something that
they should change for their own benefit
but it needs to be something that they
can change right right but the other
thing is and the example scientific
example wanting to wear a diaper as an
adult is something you can change and
you better right you just you suck if
you're taking this on voluntarily right
that's something that the onus is on you
to fix that and not put the rest of us
to discussing the okayness of it because
it's not okay right
um and I would also just point out that
this behavior is
[Music]
um
unsanitary and is only rendered sanitary
by civilization so the point is
civilization which is making it possible
for you to play in this disgusting way
has a right to demand that you don't
right because we're you know we're going
to rescue you with antibiotics you've
got a sink with hot and cold running
water and soap made in a factory
somewhere right the point is and you
hired someone who's willing to handle
your congratulations so anyway you
have you have an obligation to cut that
out but to your point about going after
somebody who has a methodological flaw
after they've already come home and
there's nothing they can do about the
fact that their data is
compromised that's a bad version of the
story but the way that this works when
it I mean it was that's that's why I
used this like oh that really sucks for
me like but but it's but it's better
than I know now you first certainly
before I try to publish it and you know
it gets to peer review because
peerreview means nothing and then it's
out there and then you know the whole
world who's still alive and can think
goes but oh wow you published a piece of
crap you must not be a good SCI
right but you're still zoomed in too
much on the one piece of work okay and
the point is a culture of people who
honorably call each other out for Flaws
in their reasoning produces the
internalization of the critic right one
thing that is very clear somebody can
present a piece of work that looks good
right you find out whether they know
what they're talking about in the Q&A
right right when somebody says H this
looks wrong to me and they have the
answer and it's compelling and the point
is oh this person person knows the flaws
or the potential flaws and they've
plugged those holes and the work
actually is what it looks like because
they're not covering they haven't told
you stand here and this looks good if
you stand in the spot you can scrutinize
it you can push it around and it stands
up and you and sometimes the answer is
yep uh that is that is intentionally
vague because here's all the stuff I'm
going to show you a tiny bit right now
that's down stream and that's actually a
different piece of research I don't have
time to go into here but here's here's
what you saw and the the gloss of what
it means right so like some response
that indicates I know like I and and
even even if people don't say it if
there's something in them goes like I'm
glad good because I don't like I know
that there's a couple of these things
that I had to do a little bit of hand
raving because you never have time to
tell the absolutely complete story as
you know it right right but having that
stuff means that you did the homework to
make sure that the work actually is what
it says it is it's not just designed to
get you a paper right um right so
internalizing that critic is only
something that you're going to do if
other people have done the job of critic
well yep and so in any case yeah at the
point that you've come home with data
that's flawed that's because that
process was not intense enough right in
advance right that's the reason the
graduate school when it worked took many
years is that in your first year you go
out and you collect some data and then
you come back and you present it and you
get questions you can't field and you
realize what it is that you have to do
in order to make to work robust by the
time you have an advanced degree
ostensibly you've learned that lesson
and you know you know about that domain
enough that there shouldn't be any
glaring flaws yeah right but I get I
mean this may be um much more specific
to me than than most people but you and
I did that a lot since we've been
together to each other even before we
understood that we were doing it
scientifically
exactly um but for me being alone in the
field for many months at a time with you
know a field assistant um but not you uh
often I had you um and then we could do
it um together but
um the femon field season that I
collected most of the data half of my
half of the data for my uh for my
dissertation when you were not with me
and uh when I did have a field assistant
she was brilliant but she was 10 years
my junior and um and mostly I was doing
the the thinking through possibilities
and experimental design and such on my
own was the moment that I point to you
know coming back from that and then you
know and then revealing it to everyone
say okay you know poke holes in it you
know shoot it down and not having it
shot down it's like yep I thought I I
not even I thought so I mean if I'm
being honest I thought I knew it I know
I did it y I didn't I did not know
before that field season in part because
you and I had mostly traveled together
and mostly done it together I did not
know for sure of which I of what I was
capable and so
doing putting yourself at the risk of oh
God what if there's a big flaw here and
that entire like that's a year gone
right um because field Seasons being the
way they are you can't just be like well
I guess I got get right back on a plane
um but you know be be ready at the point
that you go to you know learn a ton and
like okay now I'm actually on my own and
this is where the rubber hits the road
it is
it goes to what we say in our book about
Consciousness yeah Consciousness
initially evolves in order to allow
people to pull cognitive resources but
then once you have the tool of being
able to understand what's on somebody
else's mind based on the cues that they
give you and what they say now you have
a module that can have a debate in your
own head right and that thing that can
have a debate in your own head is your
best friend because it can be a Critic
you you can have this idea that you
think might be right and then you can
have a Critic say well that here's the
ways it might not be right and the point
is by the time you get to an actual
discussion with somebody else you've
already had the debate right um so
anyway yeah um and if we forbid
criticism you don't develop that and you
end up with diapers
Spa I
guess I think I mean if you forbid
criticism this is where we land yeah if
you forbid criticism and if you uh start
thinking that every time a person is
uncomfortable something has gone wrong
rather than right a person is feeling
uncomfortable because that's a natural
process by which we get better yes um
then you end up there
yeah all right I think we're good I
think we we've done it I think we did it
uh we will uh be back in a
week um with another live stream in the
meantime uh please subscribe to our
channel on Rumble uh and
um even if even if you most just listen
come over to rumble subscribe to the
channel it it actually helps us out and
uh become a member at locals where we've
got um some great uh locals only content
and we're putting up more all the time
and we do we did this private Q&A just
uh this last weekend which is still
available and uh do some amas and um
lots lots of good stuff there so um
those are the places we're really trying
to encourage people to go to I also
write at natural selections. substack
uh.com every week this week I wrote
about
um the carbon footprint of urban food
versus uh con conventionally grown food
and how actually our Alma moer put out
research that suggests the carbon
footprint of um of the food that people
who just want to grow food in their
backyards is higher and so they should
really stick to buying the crap that you
can buy at the store it was an
embarrassing piece of research I wrote
about that I also wrote about the origin
of shoulders which um comparative
anatomist to me came out I'm really
excited about this you wrote about the
origin of shoulders are you going to do
a followup on the temperature of
shoulders
uh no what does that mean cold shoulders
I'm thinking oh um I mean you want to do
a guest post on natural
selection yes but not not about cold
shoulders maybe about soft shoulders
soft shoulders yeah I thought somehow I
was thinking about roads I was the
temperature of shoulders on roads I no I
hadn't gotten there yeah no yeah okay um
and of course we have uh some cool merch
at dark Darkhorse store.org um straight
up just Darkhorse stuff uh we've got a
nice shirt cut that out cut that
out yeah that's that's that's good
stuff actually we had to send a stack of
those to the to the diaper spot people
wow yeah okay it's it's a little bit too
literal though it's a little too literal
yeah but I don't know maybe they'd get
the message on the other hand we could
be convicted of
bullying yeah yeah yeah we got Jake's
micro pizza if you're in a place place
where you're being asked to wear a mask
just eat some micro Pizza they can't ask
you to mask while you're eating can they
no that it's impossible you can't do it
I mean as Tiny as Jake's micro Pizza is
it it does not get through the pores of
a mask so you have to you can't wear the
mask while you're eating it nothing
nothing to be done blueberries because
oxidant happen MH mhm visor the
breakthroughs never stop they really
don't it's a good one anyway lots of
good stuff there at Darkhorse store.org
um and we do still have uh have
conversations at uh at actually your
patreon conversations this weekend yes
um so that that's happening and um and
check out our sponsors this week which
were Maui Nee venison American Hartford
gold and free
spoke uh and until we see you next time
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well
everyone all
right
[Music]